Salut les Épicurieuses et les Épicurieux !
Faut-il mettre de l'huile dans l'eau de cuisson des pâtes ?
J'en vois certains qui lèvent les bras au ciel
et d'autres qui sourient.
La question divise.
Les pâtes et l'huile,
ce n'est pas le seul sujet en cuisine sur lequel les avis divergent.
Je vous donne cinq trucs infaillibles qui vont faire de vous
de véritables cordons bleus.
Pour réussir les pâtes, il faut des pâtes, bien sûr, fraîches
ou sèches, une casserole pleine d'eau et un peu de sel.
Certains vous diront qu'il
faut aussi ajouter un peu d'huile dans l'eau de cuisson.
Ils sont convaincus qu'une fois dans l'eau, l'huile entre en contact
avec les pâtes, ce qui les empêche de coller.
Ils imaginent très bien l'huile enrobant les pâtes
comme le fromage enrobe un morceau de pain, quand on fait de la fondue.
Sauf que, c'est complètement faux.
Regardez dans la casserole, l'huile reste en surface
et vous savez pourquoi ?
C'est parce que l'huile et l'eau ne se mélangent pas.
L'huile est hydrophobe, elle n'aime pas l'eau.
On dit que l'eau et l'huile ne sont pas miscibles.
Et si l'huile reste en surface,
c'est parce qu'elle est moins dense que l'eau.
Donc elle ne rentrera pas en contact avec les pâtes
qui, elles, sont plongées dans l'eau
et elle ne pourra pas les empêcher de coller.
Du coup, l'huile, je peux la mettre au placard ?
Et non,
car l'huile peut être très utile.
Mais juste après la cuisson, une fois les pâtes égouttées.
De l'huile d'olive. Cette fois, l'huile entre en contact avec les pâtes et elle ne colle pas.
Si vous n'aimez pas le goût de l'huile d'olive,
vous pouvez la remplacer
par une noisette de beurre ou bien une sauce,
une sauce tomate par exemple
qui, si elle a été bien préparée,
contient un peu de matière grasse, de l'huile
ou du beurre, indispensable pour la cuisson des oignons
ou des échalotes qui entrent dans la composition de la sauce.
Mais alors du coup, je la garde l'huile ?
L'huile, normalement, c'est pour le goût.
Pour que les pâtes ne collent pas,
il y a une autre technique :
il faut les faire cuire
dans un grand volume d'eau,
idéalement un litre pour 100 grammes de pâtes.
Mais pourquoi autant d'eau ?
Les pâtes sont faites à partir de farine de blé.
Du blé qui contient beaucoup d'amidon.
C'est l'amidon relâché par les pâtes qui,
au moment de la cuisson, favorise leur agglomération.
Or, en noyant les pâtes dans un grand volume d'eau, et bien, on dilue
l'amidon et on les empêche de coller les unes aux autres.
Et puis, on surveille aussi la cuisson.
Plus elles cuisent, plus elles rejettent de l'amidon,
plus elles risquent de coller.
Vous le voyez, pas besoin d'huile pour cuire les pâtes,
juste un peu après pour le goût.
Oh mince, la date est dépassée.
Poubelle !
Il ne faut pas le jeter.
Un œuf reste consommable jusqu'à un mois après sa date de consommation recommandée,
ce qu'on appelle la DCR.
C'est écrit, sur la coquille de l'œuf, en rouge :
DCR
avec une date juste à côté.
À condition, bien sûr, que la coquille ne soit pas fêlée.
Si vous avez un petit doute, il existe un test très simple
pour savoir si l'œuf peut être consommé ou non.
Pour cela, il vous suffit de remplir un récipient avec de l'eau
et de plonger l'œuf dedans.
Ensuite, vous observez son comportement.
C'est lui qui est un peu fêlé ? Non ?
Pas du tout.
Si l'œuf coule comme ici, ça signifie que l'œuf est bien frais
et que vous pouvez le manger sans aucun problème.
En revanche,
s'il flotte à la surface comme celui-ci,
c'est que l'œuf est trop vieux.
En vieillissant, la coquille de l'œuf s'abîme.
Elle devient de plus en plus poreuse et l'œuf se déshydrate,
une partie de l'eau contenue dans le blanc s'évapore, tandis que l'air pénètre à l'intérieur
et prend la place de l'eau qui s'est échappée.
Résultat : l'œuf flotte comme une bouée.
Mais comme l'air favorise aussi le développement de certaines bactéries,
il ne faut pas le consommer.
Enfin, un dernier cas de figure :
lorsque l'œuf se positionne à la verticale ou qu'il flotte
entre deux eaux, cela signifie qu'il n'est plus tout à fait frais,
mais qu'il reste encore consommable.
N'attendez pas trop quand même.
Faites le bien cuire, Il faut le manger à la coque, par exemple,
ou l'utiliser pour la préparation d'un gâteau.
Au passage, je vous invite à contrôler régulièrement
la DCR de vos œufs et de les consommer avant qu'il ne soit trop tard.
C'est vrai
que c'est dommage de jeter un œuf.
La poule s'est quand même un peu cassé le... pour le pondre.
Oh, ça pique ! Oh je m'y ferai jamais !
Vous aussi, ça vous est sûrement déjà arrivé.
Mais pourquoi pleure-t-on quand on coupe un oignon ?
Quand la lame pénètre dans le bulbe,
des milliers de cellules qui le composent sont percées.
Le liquide qu'elles contiennent se retrouve à l'air libre.
Ce liquide contient des composants soufrés qui, au contact de l'air,
se transforment en gaz, en oxyde de propanethial.
Ce gaz se diffuse très facilement autour de l'oignon
jusqu'à atteindre notre visage.
Jusque là, tout va bien.
Mais en arrivant au niveau de nos yeux,
il réagit avec le liquide lacrymal.
Il se transforme alors en acide sulfurique.
Quoi ? De l'acide sulfurique ?
Pas de panique, les quantités produites ne sont pas suffisantes
pour présenter un quelconque danger.
En revanche, nos yeux sont irrités.
Du coup, ils se défendent.
Nos glandes lacrymales
se mettent à produire des larmes pour les nettoyer.
Sauf que plus on pleure, plus l'oxyde de propanethial a de quoi réagir,
plus on fabrique de l'acide sulfurique.
C'est un véritable cercle vicieux.
Pour que ça se calme, il suffit d'arrêter de couper les oignons et d'attendre
que les larmes aient assez coulé pour éliminer les composants irritants.
Mais pour éviter ce désagrément, il existe quand même quelques astuces.
Te fatigue pas ! J'ai trouvé un truc.
Bonne idée, mais à condition que tes lunettes de plongée soient bien hermétiques.
Le problème, c'est que tout le monde
n'a pas des lunettes de plongée
à portée de main dans sa cuisine.
Moi, je préfère utiliser un couteau bien aiguisé,
un couteau qui coupe très bien.
En réalisant des coupes nettes,
on perce beaucoup moins de cellules remplies de liquide
et forcément, on libère moins de composés soufrés dans l'air.
On peut aussi couper l'oignon sous un filet d'eau, juste à proximité.
Au contact de l'eau, le gaz irritant se transforme en acide sulfurique qui s'écoule
directement dans l'évier sans atteindre nos yeux.
L'autre solution, c'est de placer
l'oignon une vingtaine de minutes au congélateur.
Au moment de le couper, le liquide a commencé à se figer
et il y a donc moins d'émanations de composés soufrés.
Malin, non ?
Elle n'est pas fraîche !
Et les invités qui arrivent dans une demi-heure !
Vite ! Au freezer !
C'est un réflexe logique, mais il y a une meilleure solution
pour refroidir rapidement une bouteille de champagne.
Dans un freezer, la température atteint -18 degrés.
Or, à cette température, il faut environ 1 h
à une bouteille qui se trouve au départ à température ambiante,
autrement dit, aux alentours de 20 degrés,
pour descendre à 8 - 10 degrés,
la température idéale pour consommer du champagne.
Si vos invités arrivent dans la demi-heure,
votre bouteille ne sera pas fraîche.
C'est foutu ! On boira du Champomy.
Pas de panique, j'ai la solution.
Pour refroidir la bouteille en quelques minutes,
il vous faut de la glace, du sel et de l'eau.
Les trois en quantités égales.
Ici, 500 grammes de chaque.
On verse le tout dans un seau à champagne,
ou dans un grand saladier, si on n'a pas de seau.
Et ensuite, on plonge la bouteille dans le seau.
Vous allez voir,
en moins de dix minutes, le contenu de la bouteille va descendre aux alentours de 8-10 degrés.
C'est le résultat d'un phénomène bien connu.
Regardez, quand je mélange du sel avec de l'eau, le sel se dissout.
Les ions chlorure et sodium, qui constituent le sel, se dissocient au contact des molécules d'eau.
Et pour que cette dissolution ait lieu, il faut de l'énergie.
Et bien cette énergie est directement puisée dans l'eau,  sous forme de chaleur.
Si on pompe de la chaleur dans l'eau,
sa température finit logiquement par diminuer.
Mais pour que le sel se dissocie avec de la glace, il faut encore plus d'énergie.
En effet, le sel se dissocie dans l'eau liquide.
Donc, il faut d'abord que la glace fonde.
Ce qui consomme, là aussi, de l'énergie sous forme de chaleur.
Donc, sous nos yeux, dans ce seau se déroule en ce moment même
deux processus qui puisent de la chaleur :
le passage de l'état solide à liquide de l'eau,
qu'on appelle la fusion et la dissolution du sel.
La température de l'eau va donc descendre très bas et très rapidement.
On est déjà à -3 degrés, -7 degrés, -9 degrés, -10 degrés.
Et ça peut descendre jusqu'à -21.
Alors, vous allez me dire,
il fait à peu près la même température dans le freezer.
Sauf que dans le freezer, la bouteille est en contact avec de l'air
alors que dans le seau à champagne,
elle est en contact avec de l'eau et que les échanges thermiques
sont plus efficaces dans l'eau que dans l'air.
Voilà pourquoi la bouteille va refroidir plus vite
dans le seau à champagne
que dans le freezer.
Oh ! Ils n'ont pas tout bu.
Le problème,
c'est que je ne peux pas remettre le bouchon.
Pas de panique, j'ai une solution.
C'est ma grand-mère qui m'a appris ce truc.
Il suffit de placer une cuillère dans le goulot de la bouteille.
Stop !
Mais il raconte vraiment n'importe quoi.
Ça ne marche pas du tout ce truc.
Des scientifiques se sont même penchés sur la question.
En 1995, des chercheurs du Centre interprofessionnel
des vins de Champagne ont voulu vérifier si ce geste avait un fond de vérité.
Pour cela, ils ont débouché, simultanément, une douzaine de bouteilles de champagne
qu'ils n'ont pas vidées de leur contenu.
Ils les ont ensuite séparées en plusieurs lots, trois lots.
Un premier lot de bouteilles munies de petites cuillères dans le goulot.
Un deuxième lot avec des bouteilles rebouchées.
Et enfin, un troisième, sans bouchon.
Ces différentes bouteilles ont été ensuite pesées 24, 48 puis 72 heures
afin de mesurer la perte de gaz carbonique.
La perte de bulles, si vous préférez.
Ben oui, si des bulles s'échappent,
les bouteilles deviennent plus légères.
C'est logique.
Leur conclusion a été sans appel,
le champagne conservé à la petite cuillère
s'est évaporé tout aussi vite que celui à l'air libre.
En revanche, les bouteilles munies de bouchon
ont conservé leurs bulles un peu plus longtemps.
Cela dit, après 48 h, toutes les bouteilles avaient perdu toutes leurs bulles, même celles avec un bouchon.
Enfin bon, la grand-mère, elle l'a quand même pas inventé ce truc !
En fait, cette croyance vient du milieu de la restauration.
On dit qu'autrefois cela permettait de différencier les bouteilles contenant encore un peu de champagne,
de celles qui étaient complètement vides.
Certaines personnes ont pensé à tort que c'était une astuce secrète pour conserver le champagne débouchonné.
Bon bah alors ? Champagne !
C'est tout pour aujourd'hui.
Si ces sujets vous intéressent, n'hésitez pas à nous proposer d'autres idées reçues sur la cuisine.
J'aurai plaisir à les digérer
et à vous les servir sur un plateau.
À très bientôt !